the holidays mean a lot of shopping and
sadly that gives the bad guys
opportunities to steal your id in
today's la vegas now segment eric
palacios talks about how to prevent
credit card fraud
a lot of people
shopping this holiday season and using
their credit card and one of the things
to watch out for eric is
uh fraud it can easily happen when
you're charging things
that's true and more than ever since uh
we're on social media since
we use the internet we get emails and
now telemarketers and phishing scams
went from not just the phone but also to
our emails and our social media
yeah so there are different kinds of
fraud that take place
there are there's many different kinds
the main ones that we see is
someone calling saying they're either
from the social security administration
from the irs
and trying to get your personal
information uh some are now using the
technique of saying if you have a
high interest rate on your credit card
uh we will
we're a company that can lower that
interest rate and we work with such and
such credit card company or such and
such bank but they ask you for your
credit card uh information your address
all the your personal information and
once they have that then they're free to
use your card so it's uh it's a scam
don't ever give out your information
credit card information social security
number over the phone
so let's say somehow i stumbled into a
situation where i've been defrauded what
can i do
uh the good thing is uh your credit card
company for the most part uh has a
policy
that they will refund your money if it
was uh theft or fraud so you're normally
okay as long as you report it and you
follow their steps uh their procedures
uh for reporting the fraud and then you
will get a refund for this
any other suggestions for this holiday
season that uh will help people protect
themselves
yes always be extra careful when you're
not the one initiating the call or the
complaint if you receive a call asking
for personal information
hang up and then you call that vendor's
number or that company's number every
credit card everyone you deal with is
gonna have a 1 800 number so it's okay
to say thank you for the call i'm going
to hang up i'm going to call you up on
the number that i have for you
same thing if you receive an email
don't just reply to that email go to the
company's website
and start a claim there or start uh
communication through their website that
way you know you're dealing with the
correct company and not a scam
as always great advice thanks so much
eric thanks for having me here we'll see
you soon
all right thanks to eric palacios and
associates for sponsoring this segment
if you want more information you can
give them a call at that phone number
702-444-7777